to me the the left identity politics is
not politics as such it's a toolkit and
it's a toolkit it's like you said of CID
chrome spanners you anyone can open that
box of spanners and make it make use of
what's in there to do whatever it is
they want to do and you're starting to
see and it kind of shocks me a bit
actually because it never used to be
part of any sort of conservative
tradition with which I was familiar
you're now starting to see that kind of
identity politics emerging on the right
side of the aisle and that's very
foreign to me I never saw it and I see
it now that's well that's quite shocking
I find it quite horrible hello and
welcome to trigonometry I'm Frances
Foster I'm constant in kissin and this
is a show for you if you're bored with
people arguing on the internet of
subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our brilliant guest this week is an
Australian novelist and commentator
Helen Dale welcome to trigonometry hello
Constantine how are you hello Frances
and if you don't I will
[Music]
anyone who hasn't watched trigonometry
before has now been fully briefed on how
this goes this mean you'd making fun of
each other but we've got a brilliant
guest so let's get to you Helen before
we get into the interview we wanted to
talk to you primarily about the
Australian elections which is a big
thing that's happened recently but
before we do that just tell everybody
who are you how you come to the place
that you're in now how do you happen to
be sitting in this rather uncomfortable
chair right here in Australia my claim
to fame and this does go back a few
years ago now is I won the Miles
Franklin award which is the Australian
equivalent of the Booker Prize and I won
it for you so I don't have to for
everybody I wanted for this book now
this is a new edition that came out in
2007
it's got multiple different covers so if
you go looking for it on Amazon you'll
see all these different colors for us
but this was 20 odd years ago now and
the Miles Franklin award put me on the
map but as a novelist not as a
commentator and then in subsequent years
I became better known as as a as a
commentator and I've probably in the UK
and whilst people here do buy my novels
they they see me as someone who writes
for standpoint and The Spectator in the
Tory graph and and that that kind of
thing and I did have one editor I won't
drop him in it take about four years to
figure out that the person who wrote the
novel that he liked was actually the
person who wrote it his back is he
provides a lot oh right that's you yes
congratulations I've only been rising at
your magazine for about six years but
that kind of thing and you've also
worked in Australian politics yes yes I
worked for two years as chief of staff
to an Australian senator senator David
Lyon helm he's not in the Senate anymore
he tried to and this is a relatively
ramen a relatively common move in
Australian politics he tried to shift
from the federal Senate and he ran for
the election in the state upper house
because it's a federal system so he
tried to go from the Commonwealth of
Australia basically the Parliament in
Canberra to the state government in New
South Wales and he failed he didn't
succeed in doing that so him and he's an
older chappies I think 68 years old so
he's basically said I think I've had
enough politics now I'm not doing it
anymore but yes I had sort of two years
in the belly of the beast working in
Canberra working for a parliamentarian
becoming very familiar with the
Australian political system and I saw
some of the turmoil in Australia I saw
for example the I was actually standing
in my senator's office in Parliament
House when Malcolm Turnbull spilt that's
the Australian term spilt the leadership
spilt Tony Abbott who was the previous
prime minister and it was all very
dramatic and do sort of this ongoing
Italy with crocodiles I call it where
Australia keeps deposing its prime
ministers and replacing them with
another one often on the basis of polls
and
people are mystified by this because the
country seems fine otherwise except we
keep changing the Prime Minister we were
talking you say sort of prepping for the
interview and you mentioned to me like
you went I'm right-wing and then you
explain something else and I just went
oh my god somebody has just said I'm
right-wing would and I think this is
very very important because I hear the
term right-wing use and it's always a
pejorative
so as an insult Lisa was it euphemism
for racism and I think we need to
detoxify what the term right-wing
actually means what does it mean to you
and why do you feel no and why do you
identify as being right-wing the
political spectrum left to right goes
back to the French Revolution and you
have to accept that people at all
different points along that spectrum are
going to disagree with each other about
what to do in this is why we have
politics it's why we have political
parties it's why we have elections in
context of the conversation though I was
talking about I one of the outlets that
I write for is Colette and qualit is now
associated with what they call the
intellectual dark web however France has
asked me yesterday and I hope I'm not
telling tales out of school by saying
this do I consider myself a member of
the intellectual dark web and whilst I
write for their magazine I don't think I
do and the reason I don't think I fit as
a member of this IDW apart from the fact
I think it's a silly name it's also
everyone else that's in it with maybe
one exception or two exceptions they're
refugees from the political left yeah
and they're they're happy unhappy with
their own team basically I am NOT a
refugee from the political left I've
always been a mixture of conservative
and classical liberal and to me and to
get onto your definition here there's
two main streams of right-wing thought
one is the classical liberal tradition
and one is the Burkean conservative
tradition and most right-wingers in the
UK and Australia are a blend of those
two I have more emphasis on the
classical liberal tradition which
is a comment about the relationship
between the individual and the state you
don't want the state to have too much
power over you the individual and that
goes in both directions you don't want
the state picking your pocket you want
to be able to keep your money and spend
it so that's that the tax and welfare
issue but you also don't want the state
telling you how to live so that can be
that can make you Pro same-sex marriage
and pro-choice but it can also make you
very opposed to banning turkey Twizzlers
Jamie Oliver yeah sugar tax alcohol
taxes cigarette taxes so that's your
classical liberal so you can look sort
of left-wing if you talk about abortion
or the nanny state or smoking or yes
particularly smoking cannabis a lot of
classical liberals are pro weed
legalization and I certainly am and so
you can look sort of left-wing if you're
dealing with choice and lifestyle issues
but then as soon as you come back to tax
and welfare policy you finish up looking
right-wing because he'll be a fiscal
conservative if you want a small lean
government you don't want it with the
ability to you know impose crushing
taxes on people you don't care I don't
particularly care about the existence of
tax havens yeah that that kind of thing
so that's your sort of classical liberal
tradition the Burkean conservative
tradition is order is hard to gain and
easy to lose the maintenance of order
depends on unspoken rules that most of
us follow without necessarily
understanding why we follow them but we
know that if we break them you get
social disorder and it's much and it's
difficult to get back to where we were
that's a terrible simplification of
Burke but what it leads to in the
British tradition is institutional
conservatism it tends to be the standard
borne by the one nation Tories and one
of the reasons why so many one nation
Tories came out four remain is because
they're actually making an institutional
argument they're saying we've been in
the Europe
Union for a really long time our
institutions are all in meshed with each
other if we attempt to leave it will be
difficult to do so that is a birkin
argument so when one nation Tories are
making it they're not making it
disingenuously it's they have a serious
case to make but you can also have one
nation Tories who say this is foreign to
Britain's traditions we have never had a
supranational state over us in this way
until you unless you go back to the
Romans and unless you want to reconsider
the European Union as the Roman Empire
and I don't think you do this is not
part of our tradition we have stood
alone we are outward looking seafaring
people as opposed to landlubbers like
they are on the continent so therefore
our traditions and our institutions
should be more focused within the United
Kingdom and not paying obeisance to the
European Union they both want nation
Tory arguments and they're both
perfectly good Berkey and institutional
conservative arguments the third strand
of conservatism doesn't really exist in
either the UK or Australia but it does
exist in the United States it's very
important there and that is social
conservatism opposition to abortion
opposition to same-sex marriage a degree
of privileges of religion a belief that
the United States is a Christian country
despite the wall of separation from
Jefferson and so on and so forth that's
much weaker in Australia in the UK or
New Zealand those kind of places much
stronger in the United States if you saw
that terrible interview where Ben
Shapiro had an absolute car crash with
Andrew Neil it was those two visions of
two but they're both conservatives Neil
is not even really a classical liberal
he's a conservative but he Neel is a
perky and conservative Ben Shapiro is a
social conservative and the two of them
it's like water and oil mm-hmm
and that's what happened in in in that
interview because they broke each
other's political compass and it was
especially bad for Shapiro who was
unfamiliar with the role of the state
broadcast I didn't know that Andrew Neal
was the chairman of the
tighter all of these kind of things but
it really broke his political compass to
deal with a person who is obviously
quite conservative but finds the
American approach to the abortion issue
completely mad that's what triggered
Shapiro wasn't the way that he phrased
the abortion quest abortion and then
Israel question yes because the
conservatives over here just are
different yeah so that's a really great
layout of the conservative spectrum by
the way I will really appreciate that
and that's something that will be really
great to have for people who want to
understand what conservatism or
classical liberal actually because I
don't think 99% of people in this
country or in the United States and
Australia have any idea what you're
talking about because the word
right-wing as Francis was saying he's
just a label now that you use for people
that you disagree with the people you
think a racist that people you think a
xenophobic it's very silly and
unfortunate because it would be it's
like you used to get a little bit of
this back when the wall came down and in
the late 80s and early 90s that anybody
was on the left was written off as a
communist and it's obviously stupid you
know Tony Blair the other one and plays
jingle bells to use the Australian
expression so I mean it's that in
Reverse basically you cannot call a
classical liberal a fascist you can't
call a Berkey and conservative like
Andrew Neil a fascist because they are
different traditions I mean and I'm not
saying that they don't necessarily agree
on certain points but fascism and
socialism and communism can line up on
certain points as well I mean they're
all they all tend to be very high tax
entities they tend to be very Pro large
states and lots of state power whereas
classical liberals and Berkey and
conservatives will be on the side of no
no no that state is too big and too
powerful we don't want to state that
that's that over-mighty otherwise it'll
crush us all underfoot and so yeah I
have seen this that oh you're right wing
and it's just used as a term of abuse
I'm working on the principle that it's
on Twitter that it's social media and so
not representative it's also creeps in
and into real life where people got all
that person's right when they're just a
massive racist yeah like you know how
people used to make preface a racist
comment by saying I'm not racist but
yeah now anyone who talks about anything
that's remotely conservative a right
wing has to preface it by saying I'm not
right-wing but yeah I think that's very
foolish because I have oh because of the
influence of classical liberalism in my
intellectual and political heritage I
mean I have whole position significant
numbers of positions that are actually
quite left-wing and that the three big
ones drugs abortion LGBT rights are
they're sort of three classical where
the classical liberals and the lefties
will line up but for different reasons
classical liberals it's because no no no
the government it should not be telling
you how to live your life the government
should not be telling you what to put in
your mouth the government should not be
telling you how to use your body that's
not the government's business the
government can go fly a kite that's the
classical liberal perspective
whereas for for left-wing people it's
more about personal liberation and being
accepted and valued based on your
identity and based on what you are I
mean I don't see necessarily anything
wrong with those arguments but they're
not ones that resonate for me for the
simple reason that if you overuse those
kind of identity arguments they can be
you know they're not just for one side
basically you can get
I always need I mean I was involved in
various LGBTQ campaigns in my youth and
I always knew I remember sitting there
when we had pride marches and so on and
so forth one day it's not just gonna be
us wanting pride it'll be everyone
likewise I remember even as a teenager
seeing sort of the beginning of the sort
of the whole black power movement and I
remember thinking okay if black powers
okay why isn't white power okay you
really might want to think about this
this is probably not a good idea maybe
in the very short term to get people to
pay attention to a particular social
issue but you don't want to persist with
it because too
the the left identity politics is not a
politics as such it's a toolkit and it's
a toolkit it's like you said of CID
chrome spanners you anyone can open that
box of spanners and make it make use of
what's in there to do whatever it is
they want to do and you're starting to
see and it kind of shocks me a bit
actually because it never used to be
part of any sort of conservative
tradition with which I was familiar
you're now starting to see that kind of
identity politics emerging on the right
side of the aisle and that's very
foreign to me I never saw it and I see
it now and it's well that's quite
shocking I find it quite horrible oh no
no that's not how you're supposed to do
things that yeah you're not supposed to
get the state in your pocket favoring
your team because of something that you
are and we're specifically talking about
when you talk about identity being used
in that way on the right were you
starting to see genuine
ethno-nationalism I've started to see
that that had been killed that had been
absolutely put in its box
you know Enoch Powell was thrown out of
the Conservative Party for even getting
a tiny bit near those kind of
perspectives there are quite a lot of
people out there now who sort of a quite
blunt about that and also the use of
true facts things that are true are
construed in an identity Rhian way and
I'll give you one from each side of the
political aisle so you can see what I
mean
white boys in Britain do particularly
working-class white boys do poorly at
school though the bottom rung of the no
the bottom rung of the ladder yeah
instead of saying we need to address
disadvantage in this country there are a
significant number of voices saying we
need specific programs for poor white
boys in exactly the same way that if you
go back 20 years we need specific
programs for poor black kids or we need
anti Islam a phobia programs for Muslims
or as far as I'm concerned and this is
very much the classical liberal side
rather than the conservative side this
is all nonsense you
can't do this because of the toolkit
quality of it
do you hate to address disadvantage do
you have a donation yeah instead of
targeting negative targeting particular
groups because the thing is by targeting
particular groups you finish up in a
situation where you treat everybody in
the group as a widget you know they're
all the same and that's fraught with
danger it doesn't matter what group of
people that you're dealing with you
absolutely fought with danger and and
and and it and because of the toolkit
quality anyone can use it including
really quite reprehensible people on on
both extremes so you get the the white
identitarian is a more ethno-nationalism
are using the wrong hand you sort of on
the on the right hand side but you're
now also getting you're starting to see
um elements of it on the political left
with in in in this country with the
approach to Israel in the Labor Party
you know instead of just having an
argument about oh we should recognize
Palestine as a country or we should stop
selling arms to Saudi Arabia which are
our legitimate arguments and and Corbin
is not a fool for for making both of
them historically it's become awful
arguments you know you say you've got
people in the labor party tweeting Ross
shield means and you know and noopy
conspiracy murals with loopy conspiracy
theories in them you know it's sort of
that's the same thing on the other side
it's just you just don't want to go
there guys we wanted to take a moment
just to say thank you to every single
one of you who has supported us on
patreon who sent us money through PayPal
we genuinely could not do the show
without you having said that we've now
also found a corporate sponsor to sell
out to absolutely and it is the magazine
the week and the week is a news filter
that pulls together the best articles
from over 200 different sources from
publications such as The Telegraph the
FT or for our one liberal snowflake fan
The Guardian exactly and that's what
they do they do exactly what we do on
the show which is pull together
information from different sides of the
debate the left and the right so you
don't find yourself stuck in an echo
chamber and you can make your own mind
up and if you want to make the most of
this offer visit the week
dot UK forward slash offer and use our
special code which is trigger for your
six three issues of the week what the
week does is it allows you to read less
and no more which is gonna appeal to
people like Frances you can barely read
absolutely and it's not just news as
well it's also sports or if you're
interested in football you want to find
out the latest details at the transfer
window they will have in that in there
as well which won't appeal to
Constantine because he's a virgin the
seriously guys we know that you've got
busy lives you're not going to be
reading two hundred articles a day and
what the week does is combine all those
things in one easy package that you can
look at once a week and know what's
going on join thousands of trusts a week
as their essential curator news source
try it for yourself of your first six
issues completely free to take advantage
of this great offer visit the week code
at UK forward slash offer enter our
special code which is of course trigger
and you will get your first six issues
of the week completely free about the
election let's get into it because
Francis and I I don't know if it's fair
of me to say on behalf of Francis but
it's certainly something I know nothing
about and what I did see however is when
the election happened a it was not
predicted by people including you
yourself I didn't realize you didn't
expect it to happen the polls had
predicted for I think 56 consecutive
polls had predicted that it wouldn't
happen that way you have a right wing or
certainly a center-right government
retaining its power which was unexpected
a lot of people have likened it to
brexit and Trump the thing that I saw
and all over my Twitter was oh we're
living in this racist sexist xenophobic
blob exactly the same thing to happen
with Breck sir exactly the same thing
that happened with Trump so basically a
bunch of woke people freaking out which
always makes me happy so I looked at
this and I thought well let's get
someone in to talk about it so why don't
you tell us what happened why you think
it happened and what are some of the
correlations with Trump and brexit is it
the same thing is it something different
etc okay I'll try to work backwards
through that
there is some similarity with Trump and
with brexit and also with the 2015 UK
general election in that it was an
unexpected victory and Australian
pollsters were humbled very badly
including the leading polling company in
Australia called News poll which is
actually run by the newspaper that I
cover brexit for I write for the
Australian which is the country's main
national daily and the Australian owns
news poll and it had always been had a
very good reputation for being an
extremely accurate poll now there are
reasons for that which I'll get onto in
a in a minute but certainly it was an
unexpected win and of course it was a
win that went to a center-right
government where it's different from the
Trump phenomenon and particularly
different from the Trump phenomenon and
also to a degree from brexit but not
that different is Scott Morrison the
Australian Prime Minister and the
Liberal National Coalition are to the
left of the US Democrats oh wow okay you
need to understand you need to
understand the the difference in
politics between a orderly prosperous
extremely well governed Commonwealth
country and the United States
Australians look at the United States
I'll be quite frank and they just look
at the United States and go it that's a
failed state called trigonometry for a
reason breathe breathe yeah so for
example to give you an idea Australia
has universal health care all the things
that the Americans are always tearing
themselves apart over and not only does
it have universal health care it has
extremely good universal health care you
know it has fully funded pensions none
of this problem of the huge debt of
Social Security in the in the United
States it has zero almost zero gun crime
and when Democrats want to beat the
Republicans over the head in the United
States about their gun laws they always
point at Australia but
the very strict gun laws that exist in
Australia post and big massacre posing a
big massive Arthur after the Port Arthur
massacre
so for example there are some quite
conservative individually socially
conservative people either in the
Liberal National Coalition or who have
been in it historically but because
Australia has particular characteristics
as an electorate the social conservatism
never really gets anywhere for example
historically a man who's just lost his
Sikh Tony Abbott clearly wanted to
tighten up abortion laws and John Howard
the then Prime Minister basically got
Tony Abbott while he Tony Abbott was the
Health Minister grabbed Tony Abbott by
the scruff of the neck and went sit down
and shut up
we want to stay electable so Australian
politics is very centrist and there is
not a huge gap or there hasn't
historically between being a huge gap
between the coalition the Liberal
National Coalition and labour there's a
reason for that and I've tried to
explain it in a little podcast of my own
but I'll do it a bit here Australia has
a very unusual electoral system it's
like nowhere else on the planet and the
most important thing you need to
understand about the Australian
electoral system is that voting is
compulsory so you don't have any issue
in Australia with getting the vote out
and also if you're too nutty in your
policies too far to the left or too far
to the right where they're on the Left
it's about identity politics or
[Music]
environmentalism on the right about
things like abortion or cutting welfare
or all that kind of thing if you go too
far in one or the other direction
because all of the people vote you truly
get a distribution that looks like that
and the great bulk of the population is
in the middle of that distribution and
if you are too weird they will not vote
for you to sound Laureus
of pandering to your base he's actually
a very bad strap it's a very bad
strategy don't pander to the base both
parties have made mistakes doing this
recently it was the Labour Party but it
was and that's one of the reasons they
lost that election but it's also the
coalition has made the same mistake
typically at state elections they tried
to pander to their social conservative
base in Victoria and they were critical
of for example a drug injecting room
that's available for drug users in
Victoria they were critical of education
about same-sex relationships in
Victorian schools and just discovered
that they did not take the Victorian
people with them at all got creamed at
the state election so you get this
centrifuge of driving people's policies
to the centre now so that people don't
think that either you guys at
trigonometry or I am around to ask how
the Australian political system works
and why it does I've mentioned the
compulsory voting and the effect that it
has if you want to understand the
Australian political system read this
book and hold it up there for our
listeners is from secret ballot to
democracy sausage yes from by Judith
Brett she's a professor of political
science at an Australian University I
think at Melbourne University and the
democracy sausage refers to the fact
that Australian elections they're held
on a Saturday so there are like a
carnival atmosphere and it is customary
for them to be held in places where
local community groups run by schools by
Surf Life Saving clubs by the police
youth clubs by Scouts by Guides put food
stalls on to raise money so one of the
experiences that Australians have when
they go to the polls all of them they do
go to the polls is it's a carnival
atmosphere it's like a holiday
and so people eat food and the democracy
sausage if the Twitter hashtag you know
oz votes 19 had a slice of bread with a
sausage on it and tomato sauce that was
the sort of classic it's not a hotdog
it's on a slice of bread you have to ask
especially when you go to one of the
store
an Australian like their appalling place
officially but Australians always refer
to them as polling booths and it's so
it's a very carnivalesque kind of
atmosphere it's a very attractive sort
of atmosphere and it's a very unusual
system and the reason this book starts
the title is from secret ballot is the
secret ballot as you experience it when
you walk into a little cubicle and you
have a pencil there and your ballot
papers that cubicle and the ability to
hide how you're voting in its modern
form there was a version of it in
classical antiquity but this is a
separate modern invention the modern
form is actually an Australian invention
and when it was first developed in the
late 19th century for a long time people
in other countries in both the UK and
the United States referred to it as the
Australian ballot because it was an
Australian invention but so what's the
impact of that tell us about the impact
the innovation well it well the secret
ballot the importance of the secret
ballot is that people can't be
frightened in or bribed into voting a
particular way you don't know how
they're going to vote and that is the
virtue of the secret ballot is that you
find out what people really think in
economics economists talk about the
difference between stated preferences
and revealed preferences
the secret ballot is the way that you
get revealed preferences and it's also
why most recently in Australia although
this hasn't happened before in Australia
but in many many other countries why the
way people vote in the polling booth is
different from the kind of things they
may have told pollsters and this
phenomenon has become more common on the
political right because people are
afraid to say what they think they think
they'll be criticized for it may be
legitimately maybe maybe not but people
don't often like to be criticized for
their political views so they don't say
anything but then they go into the
secrecy of the polling booth and say on
the ballot paper what they really think
and that phenomenon has
was first identified in 1992 when John
Major unexpectedly
won a general election here and it was
called British pollsters called it the
shy Tory syndrome it doesn't always
happen and UK pollsters since they were
embarrassed by it again in 2015 have
generally become quite good at
controlling when you feed all the data
through polling through your yes your
poll a Greg ages have become quite good
at controlling for the shy Tory syndrome
which is why for example in 2017
servation did really well they that they
picked the UK general election almost
down to the seat the seat numbers they
did really really well you can do that
you can do very good accurate polling
it's not impossible but you have to be
really aware of all the the factors that
are flying around but in this case they
were quite low you weren't there was a
point you may take over the phone yes
yes Australian pollsters because of the
compulsory voting in other countries
pollsters have three existential issues
that they have to deal with is the
person that I'm asking number one is the
person that I'm asking questions of even
going to vote number two does that
person form part of a representative
sample and number three is that person
telling me the truth those are three big
things so when one of them goes wrong
number three for example is it shy
Tories they have to be controlled for by
the polling company number one likely or
unlikely voter sometimes they ask them
directly but then you've got a problem
with number three again they might lie
Oh someone's asking me about whether I'm
going to vote alright I better say yes
so you get completely false impressions
about turnout and number two which is
where the Australian pollsters went
wrong is they had problems with getting
an accurate sample some of this wasn't
their fault there's a
Bank of telephone numbers called the
government integrate integrated number
database that police and emergency
services use in Australia and pollsters
Pauline companies like news poll the one
at my own newspaper have been pleading
to be allowed access to that for many
years now because they were aware that
they were eventually if you don't have
access to a full Bank of telephone
numbers including mobile numbers you
start getting difficulties with a
representative sample however in other
respects they were lazy because
one-third of the things that really
matter for pollsters in the United
States or France or the UK worrying
about is this person going to vote they
didn't have to care now that's a big
when you've got three questions you have
to answer and suddenly one of them
doesn't matter it becomes much easier to
control in the other areas and get
accurate forecasts now when I was
working for Senator Lyon helm in 2016 we
had in-house polling that we did we
commissioned polling companies to do
stuff for us and ask the questions and
came up with the frameworks and so on
and so I've done all of this myself as
as a as a chief of staff to a politician
but we also use publicly available polls
like news poll and my experience of them
was always that you could rely on them
Australian pollsters were very very good
they got very accurate throughput
because of the compulsory voting and
even and it this must be said it even
must be said the Saturday election that
they got wrong with their 56 news polls
in a row indicating that Labour was
ahead of the coalition particularly in
the last couple of weeks of the election
the gap was within the margin of error
do you know what that means the margin
of error yeah when I give the gap is in
the margin of error it literally means
it could go the other way and a huge
number of pundits don't pay enough
attention to the margin a margin of
error
the only polls you really should have
taken into account of those 56 were the
ones where the lead to labour was above
the margin of error or outside of the
margin of error and sometimes it was so
you clearly in those places you've got
other issues sampling problems in shite
korie's but where it was in the margin
of error particularly in the weeks the
tightening of the polls and the lead-up
to the election more pundits including
people at the Australian newspaper and
they are completely frank about this now
like journalists I've been interviewed
by in Australia both for the Australian
and for his show on Sky News Chris
Kenney even he admitted he said yeah by
I have not paid enough attention to the
fact that the polls tightened before the
election and that you had a situation
where it was within the margin of error
and all that means is you could
literally just fall in the opposite
direction so you you can't blame
pollsters for pundits being in humorous
is that and you also can't blame
pollsters for people lying to them I
mean they can control for it too for
something like shy Tories to the best of
their ability but in Australia they've
never had to do that before that's a new
experience all right so that's all great
and what were the main issues in the
election because you say it's a much
more centrist place so does that mean
for example in issue like immigration
was much less of a thing than it is here
completely non-issue in the last
election really immigration did not that
the two really big issues in the last
Australian election that really mattered
and that annoyed people on both sides
were climate change and tax okay and a
little bit of background here Australia
not only has compulsory voting it also
has Instant Runoff or compulsory
preferential voting which is where you
number the boxes the cover of the book
does it really well with the letters
yeah you number them all in ranked order
and the one refers to the primary vote
and then the subsequent numbers are the
preferences it's possible much easier to
register a protest vote and I'll use
British political parties here rather
than an Australian one so that you get
what I mean you're angry with the canoe
had the Australian voting system you're
angry with the Conservatives because
don't like the way they've handled
brexit so that means you vote number one
for a protest party for UK or the brexit
party and then number two for the
Conservatives so you've given the
Conservative Party a pop on the snoot
for doing their job badly but you've
also awarded them eventually if the
number of votes that's either you keep
all the brexit party get is less than
the number of votes that the
Conservatives get the preferences will
flow ultimately to the Conservatives now
what has happened in Australia over many
decades now is that the Labour Party's
primary vote the number of ones it gets
in its boxes has been dropping and
whilst it's often been able to form
government because it gets preferences
from other parties the way funding works
in Australia for a political party is
determined on how many number ones you
get it's deter based on your primary
vote and now the political party that's
been taking votes from the Australian
Labor Party is the greens and the Greens
have run very hard on climate change
issues and they ran very hard in this
last election campaign on a coal mine
that was going to be built in the
Carmichael Basin the Adani coal mine
Adani is the name of the Indian company
which is involved in funding and
building this mine it hasn't been
started yet there's been all sorts of
fights there was an enormous fight over
the Adani mine in 2015 when I was
working for Senator lion help so this
has been a persistent ongoing issue huge
climate change huge fight over climate
change Indian colonialists coming
pillaging the country's resources and
anyway yes there was something there are
some people who literally ran that line
which is really quite extraordinary the
greens were running the environmentalist
line and a number of things happened
with Adani Adani is in Queensland or
will be in Queensland the Queensland
state government has just put the
approvals through because it's a Labour
government it's sort of like oh whoops
this appears to have lost labour the
election we've better change our tune so
it's in Queensland Queensland is a very
resource
rich state coal oil diamonds natural gas
uranium it's got everything basically
and so the mine was going to be in
Queensland there was an enormous
environmental fight over it and labor
angry legitimately I think at the loss
of its primary vote over many decades
moved closer to the Greens which was
opposed to the building they were
opposed to the to the canoe it's an open
cut so Oh
opposed to the mine basically rather
than the traditionally the Labour Party
would have said no this is providing
thousands of jobs for good jobs that
either the line that Donald Trump uses
about good jobs for working-class people
who aren't necessarily terribly skilled
but they're hard-working and if they're
willing to work in a remote location
they finish up getting a very high
salary and that phenomenon of working in
a remote location and working for say
two weeks at the mine and then having
four days off going four or six days off
going back to a big city is known as
FIFO in Australia fly-in fly-out and
this is very very common in Queensland
and the city where I first practiced law
I first went to the criminal bar in in
Australia as a city called Rockhampton
which is right on the periphery of one
of the two big coal areas the Bowen
Basin so there's the Bowen Basin and
then further inland there's the Galilee
Basin which was where the Adani mine is
going is going to be now and all these
people in those areas many of them
indigenous many of them Pacific Islander
many of them all of them quite often
quite disadvantaged educationally and
socially and some working-class
traditional labour voters they would
have expect they expected the party of
the worker to be in favour of good jobs
for people like them and what happened
is that Labour's primary vote in
Queensland went down even further went
down to 27% which is just unsustainable
you know so the number of people who
were willing to put labour number one on
the ballot paper was only 27% think in
terms of first-past-the-post how likely
is it if you have a seat with four or
five people running that a person who
only gets two
7% for the vote is going to win in
first-past-the-post it's very difficult
and so Labour's primary vote collapsed
even further and people instead of
preferencing a minor party like one
nation or the United Australia party and
then going back to labour
they then preferenced and went to the
coalition so there wasn't much shift on
the at the number one level but the
preference flows were 1012 sometimes 15
percent in favor of the coalition so
labour lost all of its regional seats in
Queensland except one and that it was
the mine climate changed the mine issue
there was a mine what did it yeah and
but there was another reason that I
found very interesting on your podcast
listening to it it was because Labour
prioritized the LGBTQ vote and which
alienated the Pacific Islander vote yes
and it was all because of a rugby player
yeah well I mean this is this is what
led to the shot I am reasonably
satisfied now having done a booth by
booth analysis in two of the seats that
Labour lost and one seat that it very
nearly lost at Queensland seat did it
very nearly lost seats with a very
significant concentration of Pacific
Islander voters and I mean you won't
know what they are you won't know what
they are Pacific Islanders our people
from you know sort of Vanuatu who cook
islands in New Zealand from Hawaii Tonga
Fiji there lots and lots and lots of
them in Australia going back over over a
hundred years Pacific Islanders were
brought often forcibly to Australia in
the 19th century to cut sugar cane and
they were referred to this is quite a
vulgar word in Australia now but it's
historically accurate they were referred
to as kanakas and they were a form of
indentured labour so there is a
significant going back I don't know that
were but I am now worried we're gonna be
monetized forever
oh you're getting now is just me getting
what I used to call as a teacher SPS
which is sweating back syndrome no
sweating back we can just feel the sweat
let's not explore so you haven't dropped
their bond but you know it's it that was
the term that used to be used it's not
used now it's not as rude as the n-bomb
and there are certainly brutal words in
Australia than that as Australia as a
significant Pacific Islander population
and the Pacific Islands the missionaries
who went there were almost uniquely
successful compared to everywhere else
in the world and they're a mixture of
Pentecostal Presbyterian methodist
uniting yo so know all different
varieties of Protestant they're not
Catholic they're all varieties of
Protestant and they're quite
traditionally conservative and religious
and they have this very similar moral
values to Muslims except as i i've
pointed out to a few people except
they're they're completely monogamous
obviously cuz that's part of
christianity and israel philau who was
the rugby player in question put up on
his instagram a homophobic I don't do
Instagram except for pictures of my cats
are not sure how it works a homophobic
mean basically that among other things
said that gay people were going to go to
hell and of course he's the best rugby
player in Australia he is a
multi-millionaire from being a rugby
players enormous ly gifted and this
caused an enormous stink because he'd
violated rugby Australia's social media
policy and so there was this ongoing an
enormous stink that just dragged on and
on and on because you know have these
sporting bodies they have their own
internal rule requirements in terms of
dispute resolution and so on and so
forth and then you can go through the
courts and then you can go through an
employment tribunal and all of this kind
of thing and all the different stages of
this over a conservative Christian rugby
player what's just going on at the
time as the election campaign and an
organization called the Australian
Christian Lobby did what I used to do
for my senator when I was working for
him did private polling about the effect
of the treatment of Israel Folau
was having not only among Pacific
Islanders but just among Christians more
generally and it soon became clear that
even many people who were not a
particularly Christian were looking at
it from the perspective of powered
sports people Australia is a proud
sporting nation has got OD sporting
significant sporting heritage it's taken
very seriously in the country and
Australians are very good at sport and I
hope the country wins numbers of Olympic
medals out of all proportion to its tiny
population every Olympics and all of
this kind of thing so a lot of people
were just looking at the Israel for our
situation and going this is to do with
his ability to play rugby how and why do
you even care and even a couple of other
people who were either sort of X
Wallabies and X Waratahs which is his
stateside New South Wales Waratahs we're
saying we it's not just Israel Folau
you'll have to get rid of every Pacific
Islander in the Australian rugby team
because that's what they were all like
they just don't necessarily stick it on
their Instagram but that's what they all
think they're conservative Christians
are you going to get rid of all of the
Pacific Islanders out of the Australian
rugby team and if you do isn't that a
bit racist because it's this it's the
same argument that you have with Islam
over here if you start picking on people
for having really really conservative
religious views and most of those people
are Muslim and most of those people are
brown on you might not mean it but it
can start to have a racist a racial
effect in Australia it's it's Pacific
Islanders if you start chucking every
Pacific Islander out of the rugby team
for having conservative religious views
they're gonna lose ever again we
surrender to New Zealand might as well
say that but you're also you're getting
rid of all of the brown players in your
team and you'll finish up with a team of
only white players
and nobody in Australia probably would
be quiet no man and no matter how you
dress that up that's going to look bad
so a lot of people what you're saying is
a lot of people felt that what we might
call the progressive left had gone too
far in the way that Israel was dealt
with yes and as a consequence of that
and some air in some electrics it's
transferred in it transfer I'm
reasonably satisfied now having done a
booth by booth analysis that it
transferred into votes for the coalition
or at least preferences to the coalition
they might have put number one for you
know a local for a protest party and
there's lots of those
but they've their preferences flowed to
the coalition rather than to late right
so the environment was an issue the kind
of protection of what you might call
freedom of expression or socially just
freedom areas for yeah that was an issue
but the real big issue that amazingly
you talk about is the economy actually
economy hasn't affected the Western
elections it's certainly in the UK
Britain or in the UK or America for
quite a while with some people yeah it
was it the other one was a tax issue
yeah not so much it's the overall
economy huh Australia's economy is great
you know there's not been a recession in
Australia for 28 years Wow
the last recession was in 1991 I'm an
old lady and I barely remember it okay I
mean I was just out of high school
hmm to give you an idea of I mean it was
so long ago and I can't sort of really
remember many of the details cuz you
can't when you kind of nineteen it's
yeah that that kind of thing and so the
Australian economy is fine highest
minimum wage in the OECD lowest
unemployment that's not going to be an
argument the argument in this case and
I'm going to be very brief here because
it's otherwise we'll just get into the
weeds with corporate law and tax policy
and that's fine and entertaining for me
because I used to be a corporate lawyer
but it's not very entertaining for your
listeners it will be entertaining for
the one listener
very briefly Australia doesn't have
state pensions in the same way as the UK
you don't get one automatically you have
to be poor the social expectation in
Australia and it's imposed by law is
that you are meant to provide for your
own retirement and you are meant to put
money into what is called your
superannuation fund which is your
pension now this is compulsory everyone
has to do it's like the voting system
it's been compulsory for a very long
time since 1990 and it means that the
majority of people in Australia have
fully or partly funded pensions they
don't have to hold their hand out to the
government to get money when they're old
however an entire thicket of rules
around super-super Australians call it
super have developed over the years and
that make it easy to do this that mean
you pay less tax that mean that when you
get money from your share investments
you pay less tax or you get a rebate and
so on and so forth and one of the
rebates that Pete a lot of people in
Australia not just pensioners but a lot
of people were getting was known as
franking credits and it's a way of
avoiding double taxation for the income
you earn from dividends and basically
the Labour Party was wanting to
massively tighten this up and make it
much harder for people to get as much in
the way of a rebate in terms of franking
credits from the government and what
this meant was that a lot of people who
are self-funded retirees who don't get
any money from the state were dependent
on franking credits on on this
particular perk that had been built into
the tax system and I am aware of
individuals for example who got in
contact with me in the lead-up to the
election who were retired self-funded
retirees no money from the government at
all their pensions are fully funded
saying I'm going to lose a third of my
income because they were getting it via
this
tax loophole but not illegal I mean it
built into the system to encourage
people to provide for their own
retirement and that caused an enormous
stink it means that anybody who had
investments where they were getting
franking credits as a result of dividend
payments on the stocks that they owned
if you were getting a significant sum of
money particularly amongst pensioners
then that just encouraged people to vote
against labour even if they were
historically low by voters because they
could just you could literally just get
a financial calculator calculator out
and work out exactly how much less you'd
have once that legislation was passed
through the Australian the relevant
legislation was passed through the
Parliament so it was a tax issue all
right I hear you so we've been talking
for a good half an hour now I don't hear
in what you've described why all these
people think Australia's as deeply
racist xenophobic place and that is the
election result is an expression of that
which is I just saw in my like I said on
my Twitter feed and on my Facebook wall
lots of Australian progressives or
whatever just going on about what a
terrible place Australia is because you
voted for this center-right Enwright
government yeah yeah Australia can look
racist to other countries but not for
the reason that many Australians give
you and also not for the reasons that
people in the UK or the u.s. give you
Australia has more immigrants per head
of population than anybody else and it's
more diverse than any other developed
country quarter of the population is
born overseas more than the u.s. more
than France more than here all the
colors of the rainbow so on and so forth
that's not the issue
Australians are Pro immigration that's
not the problem where the country is
construed as racist by people overseas
is that it has enacted a spate of
legislation over decades going right
back to the early 90s that is
effectively torn up the Refugee
Convention Australia only takes refugees
that it wants
you can't just pitch up in Australia and
claim refugee status if you do you will
be locked up mandatory detention and
that goes
to a Labour government and it was
reinforced by John Howard and you
probably heard the election slogan we
will decide who comes here and the
circumstances in which they come was
called the tamper election but John
Howard did that but the original
mandatory detention policy was
introduced by Paul Keating a Labour
Prime Minister so when people say
Australia's a racist country they don't
mean they shouldn't mean because they'd
just be wrong that it's about skin color
or ethnicity or diversity because it's
not however
Australia will not take poor crying
people who say it's unsafe for me to
live in my country and there were a
number of incidences where boatloads of
asylum seekers were simply allowed to
drown in the Timor Sea to encourage the
others to translate the French phrase
you know so they all if they realise
that they're just going to drown when
they try to get to Australia and that
stopped coming and that's precisely what
happened and the person who most
recently enforced that policy in
Australia was Scott Morrison because he
was the immigration Minister before he
became treasurer and now he's Prime
Minister but the thing is don't blame
just Scott Morrison this is a policy
that has heritage it goes back to Paul
Keating
it is baked into the Australian
settlement and the rationale for it is
that the way to stop an electorate
becoming anti-immigration full-stop
which is what the problem that you've
got in the United States and to a lesser
extent in the United Kingdom and
significantly in parts of Europe is to
give the electorate complete control
over intake if you give the electorate
complete control over intake and this is
what the former Prime Minister Malcolm
Turnbull said in that big argument with
Donald Trump when they had the big
argument on the telephone and and Donald
Trump discovered that there was a person
on the planet of course in Australia who
could swear louder and longer than he
could because Australians even really
well-educated ones who went to Oxford
like Malcolm Turnbull have a
three of the blue yeah and so Donald
Trump got an earful from Malcolm
Turnbull but in the middle of all the
swears Turnbull also made the point that
if you give the electorate control over
immigration at the national level then
90 percent of the racism and hostility
to immigration just bleeds away but the
effect of giving the electorate control
over immigration is that you have to
give the electorate control over refugee
intake so what Australia has done piece
after piece after piece of legislation
over many years by governments of all
stripes is to make it harder and harder
and harder to be a refugee in Australia
it's not that Australia takes no
refugees it does but it basically treats
them as immigrants we'll have that one
lawyer we'll have that one teacher good
that one engineer doctor plumber the
same logic that runs the points based
immigration system is extended to a
large degree even though they don't use
the same words to refugees and mediums
wouldn't make them it yeah well it's
it's it's that is and it's different
from every other country so I hear you
so the coalition as from what I take it
advocated pursuing this continuing with
this policy absolutely labor to be fair
the the way the Australian immigration
system works is bipartisan so why then
the wind the coalition when Weiser
painted as win for racism and xenophobia
because people on Twitter don't have
very many brains but also the
expectation you get on Twitter from the
Australian left the hash tag oz poll
it's one of the most contentious
hashtags on Twitter I think is probably
the best way of putting it
a lot of the the visible presence over
the hash tag oz poll on Twitter is not
actually from people in the labour party
let alone the coalition it's from greens
the greens are the party that are
opposed mandatory detention and believe
that Australia should honor the Refugee
Convention it's completely honest if you
go to the greens website you will see
they set out all the arguments but you
will also be impressed by the level of
nuance involved because they are aware
that they're coming from a minority
perspective and the Greens struggle to
break 10% of the vote and their
preferences flow to labour or have
historically flowed to label which
labour doesn't particularly like because
labour would like those primary votes
for themselves but that doesn't mean
that Labour is following the Greens on
the treatment of refugees and they
haven't and it's a very very deliberate
bipartisan policy it's why at the last
election center-right government won and
the two big issues were climate change
our Ducks later Danny mine and franking
credits tax not immigration because the
similarity between the two is the two
party the two big parties in Australia
is really they're really close and so we
talked we're talking about racism and
people consider a racist and part of it
a major part of it is of course
immigration it's a treatment of refugees
but it's also the treatment of
Aborigines and their native you know yes
notes of indigenous if there if there is
racism in Australia it's not towards
immigrants it's towards Aborigines and I
don't know whether there's much of it
left still but I saw horrible racism
directed towards Aborigines growing up
in Queensland now
Queensland was the state traditionally
is one of the two most conservative
states the other one is Western
Australia and Queensland also had a long
period of government when I was in
school I remember this I was in all the
way through primary school and nearly
all of my high school as well we had a
premier called Joe be occupied erson who
was actually born in New Zealand funnily
enough of it and so you'd make all the
New Zealand jokes you want about it very
very conservative but not only
conservative in the sense of say Ronald
Reagan or George Bush Senior but that
sort of corrupt southern conservatism
that Americans can tell tell jokes about
in those southern states they handle
snakes there to give you an idea they
used to refer to Queen
Landers the deep north based on the deep
south and some of it is stereotyping and
I mean I come from Queensland and even
worse I North Queensland which is
supposedly where all of these really
really racist people are and I certainly
saw growing up terrible racist treatment
of Aboriginal people in formal it was
never formalized but I saw things like
informal segregation so you'd have a
you'd go to country towns and there
would be four pubs three pubs would be
for white people and they'd be quite
nice and one pub would be a total bin
fire and that would be where all the
Aborigines were expected to drink and
you'd have a situation where a
middle-class Aboriginal person perhaps
they'd gone to university or done fairly
well for themselves had gone down to to
Brisbane and they'd come back in a suit
and tie er and I stress all that kind of
thing and try to walk into one of the
white pubs and get told ah no no no you
have to go to the black fellows pub
stuff like I saw stuff like that you
know this this was a real thing and you
I saw things like my parents were
farmers I saw things like my father had
a farm manager who was an Aborigine and
at once again a middle-class Aborigine
pretty successful had a nice car had a
BMW that kind of thing every time he
drove between Townsville and Cannes
which is a decent three four-hour drive
he would be booked and the only way you
could describe that was driving while
black and it has got less bad Queensland
has I had has now had a number of Labour
government's and until the recent focus
on LGBT rights in the lot really only in
the last election I have to give credit
to labour and especially to Queensland
labour for being the party of anti
racism and a huge amount of the historic
racism towards Aborigines in Queensland
especially which I can speak about
because I saw it happen was actually
dealt with it was gotten rid of by the
the Australian Labor Party in Queensland
so it's nowhere near as bad as it was
but you've got when you had like over a
hundred years of terrible racist
treatment
people having to live on reservations
there was a period where Aboriginal
people needed a pass to get off the
mission or an Aboriginal reservation it
was like South Africa this is obviously
going back before I was born but it was
still very very serious there was a
period before 1967 Aboriginal people
weren't counted in the census as if they
weren't people you know this cut this
kind of thing you can't have all of that
without there being knock-on effects and
Aborigines in remote areas are still
significantly disadvantaged compared to
not only Aborigines and not only white
people in the cities but Aborigines in
the cities as well as just a big gap
between the two health welfare education
income all of that so Helen the last
question we always like to ask is what's
the one thing that no one's talking
about that we should be talking about
I'm going to confine to confine this to
the UK and having watched a few of your
shows in the past I had thought about my
answer one of the downsides to spending
so long in the European Union was that
the UK stopped paying attention to the
Commonwealth and the best-run countries
in the world with the most innovative
social policy and economic policies are
not in the European Union they're in the
Commonwealth they're Canada Australia
Singapore Barbados Trinidad and New
Zealand extremely well run prosperous
educated places that have long histories
of economic success successful
immigration programs and excellent
health care systems by not paying
attention to the Commonwealth Britain
has fallen in in many respects behind
the countries that were once its
colonies pay more attention to
Commonwealth countries a lot of them are
doing a lot of very good stuff Helen
well that's into the interior thank you
very much here's your opportunity to
plug in novels oh right okay well apart
from the first one which I showed
earlier these are the latest - and the
these treated has have just been
shortlisted for the Prometheus award
kingdom of the wicked which is a big
science fiction
writing priors I don't know whether when
I will win it or whether I will win it
it I find out in the middle of July
apparently so
but it's just been shortly and you're on
Twitter as well and pretty active there
yes tell everybody your Twitter yeah
it's at underscore Helen Dale follow
Helen on Twitter go to her YouTube
channel buy her novels as always follow
us at trigger pod and all the social
media subscribe to the YouTube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button we've had a few donations come in
in recent weeks and want to thank you
for that if you want to support us you
can donate through PayPal or you can
become a patron subscriber that way you
get a mug if you give of a certain
amount and there's other benefits to be
gained as a final plug Francis and I are
both doing shows in August he'll be here
in London at the Bill Murray doing a
couple of shows and I'm in Edinburgh for
the full run doing my show called all
well that ends well
come and check that out as well yeah and
please leave us a nice review on iTunes
it helps to boost us up the ranking tell
people about it
retweet people share our clips if you
feel a bit embarrassed about sharing the
clip do it while I'm messing just say to
you mate this is great don't judge me
and we will see you back next week see
you later guys bye they
[Music]
here's the fall that you were asked to I
said by signing this contract this is a
UNICEF on campus SOAs right it was asked
to sign an agreement that his routine
would not contain racism sexism classism
ageism ableism homophobia biphobia
transphobia xenophobia Islamophobia anti
religion nante atheism I think you're
doing some quite complicated mental
arithmetic to offset the bad people
didn't think you were funny
you have absolutely no sense of humor
you feel like you just I mean you're
just so paying a bevin outright you know
alright that we got there in the end you
did the good thing by being automatic
needed right as i know i've got an itch
one of them is I haven't got any racist
sexist homophobic jokes I have been a
student of university where you can't
make any joke about anything he's Paul
didn't want students get upset with
drinking get over yourselves
it's not about comedy it's about
ordinary people up and down the country
and here in Britain and in America
feeling like they can't say what they
think I really don't like I get it I get
it especially especially the women who
want to become men Gareth Bale right
went from talking them to Real Madrid
the guy left a perfectly good club for
more money everybody feels like we're
we're all kind of under arrest we're all
everything we say can and will be used
against us in the court of public
opinion and can they're coming for the
comedian's first because we're we're the
ones that as you say are allowed to
transgress but everybody else feels it
and that's why this story's got the
resonance though it has
[Music]